Go back to this now, why processing is not converted as process clean text after lemmatization?
So you see that there are certain process we follow.
So it is itself a part of the text cleaning.
So first of all lower casing, then we remove the punctuations and the special characters,
then we do the tokenization.
In tokenization what we do, like if it is a sentence like I love programming, I love
programming these three parts, we just separate it out and then we for example, we remove
the stop what if something stop what is present and then finally we go for the lemmatization
as a text cleaning part because if those what already you have refined tokens which are
present there.
So we just make them go back to their root words, like if something is present like running,
so go back to their root word run or if it is skipping, we go back to their root word
skip.
So this is why we follow this type of the sequential steps in the text cleaning purpose.
So can you go to the next question, so these two questions are quite analogous to each
other question one and question two, I think the queue we have not marked as two, so both
are the same similar meaning that in analyze sentiments, why are we considering only the
first sentiment result, result equals to sentiment analysis feedback 0 or the result equals to
sentiment analysis.
A second question is also same, result of feedback 0 like I mentioned during the AI leadership
part.
So this particular part 0, which is which is the index value that is present there.
So this particular index has the highest, I mean most important part of the sentiment
outcomes.
If this is the index part is 0, which is the it containing the most significant part of
the sentiment outcome.
So that is why we have taken this particular particular implementation with the help of
the index 0 after sentiment analysis feedback.
So you can check out in the notebook, even in the notebook it is present.
If you see the hash sign after if you go to that particular explanation, I also have written
each and everything is written in the code.
So those of which we are asking me, it is written in the code already.
I have explained them and I know that those who are new to it, for you it is required.
So each of the line, if you check each line of the code, if you go to my notebook, not
only this one, today's NLP class, I mean supervised machine learning also, everywhere
each clarification is given there, because I know all of you are new to it, so it will
be required.
Is there any more question?
Thank you very much for joining today's session.
So I am thankful to the TCSIAM team for their wonderful moderation.
Here also from our side, Mr. Devjit, Subrata Naik and also our excellent CET team is there
in the back end.
So they are working hard.
Day and night to make this high cohort successful and I am Subrata Chimukopadhyay who actually
have taken your NLP session, signing off today.
Thank you very much.
Have a great weekend ahead and we will meet sometime soon.
I am hoping so actually.
If I get the opportunity, I will definitely meet you in upcoming session.
So thank you very much.